okay that magic number was 43 and this
guy got it so after E 4 we could be
entering the caro-kann I like playing
both sides of this particular variation
I like these oh okay oh my opponent
juked me right there I thought we'd be
seeing d5 so when I see this advance d6
and I've seen c6 how will this Center be
how will my opponent strike at my center
it'll be e 5 so can I take steps to
prevent that I wonder if I could invest
an additional pawn advance with f4 or
God I'll give this a try and with this
I'll try to get in Eve I've might be
seeing Knight d7 Queen c7 all moves in
other words to facilitate the e5 advance
and so night f3
Knight f3 knight c6 my main aim will be
Knight f3 e5 skying
this is a connecting connection issue
there's quite a bit of okay so I wonder
if no I I don't have to I don't have to
commit just yet this isn't a threat just
yet I have enough support for and now
now it is a threat but um you know what
I think I might want to still establish
this pawn on e5 let's do it so I'm
grabbing some space and I've invested a
lot of time to make that happen and you
know what another thing is that if my
opponent is to maybe show that this is
not a good idea on my end maybe they do
so by undermining base points of this
structure namely with a c5 strike but if
c5 is gonna be played my opponent is
also losing some time because c6 has
already been played so I think from here
I want to always have this movement
available c3 in case of c5 so I'm ruling
out I'm not I'm not considering Knight
c3 as one of my candidate moves so what
I am considering is Bishop to one of
these two squares and I don't really
think I mind this pin just yet
I could always break it with Bishop e2
I like this I'm gonna castle soon and
Bishop here like if Knight h6 to f5 I
might want to make sure I get my Bishop
on e3 and if Knight f5 I could tuck my
Bishop back to f2 in time I'd like to
get my knight on this square I think
that would be a great spot and again I
don't know if I want to really pivot on
c3 in order to do so so I might go to D
to e for once castled I'm a question
should I move my bishop first to e3 and
then play Knight B to d2 or do I do this
right away Knight B to d2 to e4 and only
then declare my Bishop to the e3 square
we're only about six moves in and both
of us have chewed up a lot of time and
okay we have that capture and I capture
towards the center let's have a good
reason not to this would become all the
more purposeful since now there's a
half-open F file and I can interpret
this as really getting what let's see
what was what was going to be my thought
on that one
I could now that this is a half-open F
file once castled I'm doing two very
good things
getting my king safe and placing my rook
on an active file so a lot has just been
accomplished with that one move King
King safety rook activity you'll also
want to do that in your own games when
it comes time to consider a king site
queenside castle if you could be
queenside castling and have that rook
placed on an open or half open file you
might want to consider doing that so I
could take him out and then this would
be a hole on f6 and I already have a
support point for it but it is defended
by the knight and it could also be
defended by the bishop
Bishop III Knight f5 Bishop back let me
do that let me reinforce this point I'm
already envisioning that this capture is
occurring and so with that d4 is going
to be my weak point I think it's too
crazy for black to try and strike at the
head of this pawn chain to to weakening
East six in particular and when we look
at time on both ends as far as who's
faster to develop were pretty even both
of us needs a single move before we're
fully developed I have to move my queen
black needs to only castle okay so Queen
here is my first thought let's go with
it
all right my opponent is not castled
he's exposed on a eight so I wonder if I
could be making use of that let me let
me throw a question this bishop see what
he's going to do this Knight could find
himself out of play if I establish an h3
g4 structure so if Bishop here I might
play g4 as weakening as it is as
weakening as it is okay this Knight is a
dead piece he's out of play I'm not
going to commit just yet let me get my
last piece working okay I'm gonna back
up and now I'm threatening this fork
okay I could push this Knight jumps in
here let me just recapture this is back
on g4 is a big threat there's also
possibilities of Queen e4 if castled
Queenie for hitting the rook while the
rook would be defended once castle but
Queenie for looking for made on h7
forming a battery so my point
sidestep stab let me throw my knight in
or no let me kick him away first and I
don't want to cap after Knight here I
don't want to capture the bishop because
it just helps out the rook
so I'm gonna play here there's only one
wheel late eight-six unless I'm missing
some trick less than a minute for black
let's get my knight involved buying two
squares d6 as a whole my dark square
Bishop could probably be doing something
better maybe I could transition since
the okay this is highly weakening I'm
gonna take that this is going to this is
going to get crushed right here on e6 I
could just take and then smash through
now clean here I have a check King here
I have a knight check this should be
crunched at this point this Knight
jumping in next ball my piece is working
these moves were a little bit shaky the
a6 and b5 prior to castling even though
I could have messed up the structure I
was still finding it difficult to do
what exactly
let me take this first hang on I have
this covered
let's just take care night here to c6 is
the big threat the Queen will have to
give herself up
there's no tricks here I'm gonna give
check and then pin the Queen that but
excuse me Rupp to see one or if King
here then there'd be a discovered check
all right good game
it's a cola Vic my quick my quick
thought is that actually from this
position up am I believe I am the better
side at this point right here but my
opponent does still have other pieces
out and this is where I would maybe go
with just coming back here or castling
and then playing Bishop here I still
have this space advantage and this
Knight is not so great if you could
somehow get him to d5 thought let's just
go all the way back real quick
beginning of the game and from your
perspective quickly maybe this has turns
out to not be a good idea if I'm able to
get in 'if I've successfully I wonder if
you could still just say you know what
I'm gonna play e5 and go with the
temporary pawn sack if I am to win upon
my pawns would be doubled and if you're
able to get that pawn back maybe then
you could be playing against an isolated
efore upon I wonder if this is available
because I think I always turn out to
better to be better if I have this pond
established on the e5 square from this
point on I have a space advantage and
it's quite cramping to you so I'm really
drawn all the way back to this very
early stage
yeah I wonder if if my opponents idea
for in the first place is to get upon
established on e5 I wonder if he should
change the move order d6 it's a more
flexible start and later on I was
talking about if my opponent is to play
their pawn up to c5 since they had
already moved c6 they're needing to
invest another move waste another move
in order to commit make that happen but
if you have d6 and then you go E 5
you're saving yourself if you if you're
going to then be striking later with c5
so I just I just wonder about the order
that that was played yeah I don't know I
think maybe e5 here might be a
possibility takes takes takes the
Queen's come off your own castle but I
don't know something to maybe look into
I'm sure the computer would light up
that it's just not a good idea from here
any other quick points oh okay I think
this is a case right here there's the
tension between these ponds I think this
is a situation where you do better to
keep the tension rather than resolve it
because capturing only benefits a my
bishop and being my rook for when I'm
castled on the F file I would this
benefits me by you capturing so keep
that tension or maybe consider closing
it up with d5 and then with the pawns
fixed as they are in the center with
your pawns on light squares you try and
get rid of your light square Bishop with
maybe Knight h6 Bishop f5 this is my
good guy
this would be my bad guy in that
instance and then could play that sort
of position maybe consider that
structural change d5 d6
and then later c5 love to invest in
another move and getting that in but I
think that's something to look into d v
e6 that the very least do not be
capturing
again it just benefits me in that case
and I think it's a persisting edge on
the white end from here on out this is
this is this turns out to be to
weakening buff or quite low on time at
that point okay
good game let me close out